Let's imagine, for example, that there
is truly only one optimal action.
Then, as we spend an infinite amount of
time running around in the world, our
notion of which action is optimal over
here, if we can convert them into actual
probabilities, will drive whatever
the optimal action is towards one.
And that just comes from all the stuff
we've been talking about with
reinforcement learning for
all the time in this class.
If we can get to an optimal policy by
just experiencing things in the world,
then eventually,
these numbers will reflect that.
And it doesn't matter
what the human thinks,
the real world will drive
the correct answer towards one.
>> So, you're saying that c
doesn't change over time?
>> c could change over time, but
let's just imagine it doesn't.
Let's just say, we pick a value for
c and it comes out this way.
If you want to say that c changes
over time that's okay, but
then we're going to deal with that
question by having these numbers here
reflect whatever we
think c happens to be.
Remember, we can keep track of all
the labels that we've seen and for any
given value of c that we have, we can
just change these numbers appropriately.
>> Okay.
>> So, it sort of doesn't matter.
At the time we ask this question,
I've got a distribution of
reactions according to the human.
I've got a distribution of actions
according to my experience in the world.
It no longer matters what I think
about the human because that is
captured by this distribution.
So I can just ask the question,
what should I do?
And here you think the answer is x.
>> Yeah.
>> Now,
what if I had different numbers here?
>> Then I still think it's x.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH]
>> What if it is this?
Well now I could certainly justify why.
>> Why.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH] Tell me why you think y.
>> So okay, so are we supposed
to imagine that the pi sub A is,
can the algorithm be wrong?
>> The algorithm could be wrong.
But in the same way that we
don't have to worry about
what's wrong with the human because
the distribution captures it,
let's make the same assumption here.
The agent, well this distribution
is going to capture all of
the uncertainty about
the agent's beliefs.
So maybe we'll never actually see 0, 1,
0, but we'll see numbers that are close
enough that I'm just
going to write out 0, 1, 0.
>> Boy, there's a lot of ways to
combine these numbers together
in which y ends up being the winner.
But it strikes me that in particular,
if we believe pi sub A, then pi sub
A is absolutely certain that it's y.
So it almost doesn't matter at
this point what pi sub H thinks,
what the human thinks.
>> Mm-hm, and by the way, with the same
argument, if it's the case that c
is equal to 1 for the human, that the
human is infallible, then it really is
not going to matter what the agent
thinks, because the human's infallible.
>> Well, unless they,
[LAUGH] unless they disagree.
But then we have to really believe
that probability is correct.
>> Right.
Either the probability is correct or
it's incorrect.
And for
the purposes of answering this question,
let's just say
the probabilities are correct.
In so far they are not it will be
reflected by these distributions.
>> So we can never have 1, 0,
0 on the top row and then 0, 1,
0 on the bottom row, because that
just violates the laws of reality.
>> Right.
>> So, you would argue for y?
>> I would.
>> I think that you've been using
intuition so far and I want you to do
a little bit more than intuition, so I'm
going to do that by writing out a quiz.